thì các bạn kảy chín, không có hỏi thế này
hỏi đây bé giảy mối thoộc nhăn hơn để trận lị vào
xúc 3 xếm đủ bé hai tôi được không acá
thì thế thấy thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay
thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thay thang
bây giờ biết là mình sẽ là khi các bạn nào nước bạn Nawet nhạy
Hãy nhé kảy ngang ká là cái mũ trưa hiểu rồi
bọn cái lộ chín trước trường học bạn luôn, nữa nhé
ở trong trước trường có thay 1, tìa cái kiếm thứ ien là Nắng
và nó mới mục gủng rất là quan trọng mà kênh cân bèo chắc cả kiểm thử đó để kiểm có một cái bất chở bị bình trọng cho kìa tất cả đúng mẹ hai.
Chứ hôm nay là chúng ta học nhang nhưng mà lơ mà kìa tất cả đúng mẹ mục tì khi đó kìa xong rồi, nó mới ai không có ý nghĩa gì cả.
Vì dùng sao của cô mình vẫn phải gọi lại ổn.